talk about a vicious cycle I call it the
Trump 360 Trump says or tweet something
outrageous the media freaks out filling
their depends with compost it's the end
of the world I mean just look at their
hair
[Music]
they had a month later they realized
damn the loud crazy orange guy had a
point and they try to forget it ever
happened look at Isis oh how they
laughed when Trump said he wouldn't tell
the media his secret plan but then not
spilling the beans worked Isis was like
whoa there goes my legs didn't see that
coming don't worry
neither did CNN now remember rebel when
Trump lectured NATO allies on defense
spending
we laughed I laughed until they agreed
to his demands I was wrong
Trump railed against trade imbalances
then well we started learning about
trade imbalances and now we have a new
deal people dragged him for his hasty
tweet about the wildfires a week later
experts admitted mismanagement made
those fires worse Trump said Puerto Rico
was plagued with corruption and that was
mean and cold and then city council
offices were raided by the FBI and
hurricane donations were found rotting
in a parking lot
remember when Trump said all judges have
political leanings chuck schumer tweeted
that trump was wrong even as chuck then
labeled john roberts a partisan and a
republican wasn't that trumps point you
preening hair plug yeah you've got you
thought you were right and he was wrong
but whoops I think I think Chris sums it
up best I remember someone teaching me
Jim
when it comes to these kinds of deals it
is voice when it happens in Reverse he
used to say to me
something something's wrong with that
man so there's there's the trend the
period between a Trump tweet and that
realization that it might be correct it
keeps getting smaller as small as a
chipmunks underpants weird visual which
says something it's not that trumps
critics have a problem with the truth
they have a problem with Trump saying it
in fact that's what outrages the media
most that even with Trump's sloppiness
he's often right
he's a cross between Einstein and a
drunk I mean I mean who here who here
doesn't like their children who here
does not like their children I do see
one hand there's nobody gotta be
somebody
children he's not lying there's a lot of
people who hate their kids I hate my
kids do not even have any now take the
caravan who kept warning everyone that
this was not gonna end well we are
sending a simple message to the lawless
caravans and to the illegal trespass is
marching toward our border it's very
simple turn back now go back home we
will not let you in hmm and how did the
media react they called the caravan a
make-believe right-wing dream this idea
unfounded of an invasion of immigrants
the president falsely described the
caravan as an invasion where everybody
out there they was telling me no it's a
real story we're worried about the
caravan they're coming and true I'm
strong enough to I'd go back to what he
said about Martians coming in my
backyard well they're not coming
boy does he look stupid no more so than
usual that's quite an achievement
because he's kind of stupid every day as
for the horror over pepper spray the
media somehow missed all the times the
Border Patrol dispensed tear gas under
Obama
I guess if Obama did it they'd call it
dispersment drizzle and I bet I bet
Trump has actually used this stuff less
because when Trump says don't come then
you don't have to spray anyone so the
media mocked Trump for the warnings now
they're really outraged that he happens
to be right the caravan arrived and
Americans were assaulted just doing
their jobs hell even the mayor the mayor
of Tijuana is pissed about the caravan
and he's the mayor of Tijuana almost
anything goes there I burned all of that
film I think a long time ago back when
you could burn film so tell me again who
are the bad guys in this equation a mob
throws bottles and hits us yet when we
respond we get blamed kind of feels like
a setup egged on by immediate drooling
for a photo so the people talking
compassion may actually care less than a
White House trying to maintain order
Trump said it wouldn't end well they
laughed then it didn't end well
and they blamed if only they could
listen to him without seeing him they
probably feel differently
we're not letting people into our
country unless they come in Legally and
we want people to come in through merit
I can't stand this guy he says terrible
things none of which are correct by the
way about the immigrants Obama made the
same point in when 2005 really well it
just sounds so much worse coming from
him having trouble admitting Trump's
right sometimes yes I am even when he
has a point I just hate it when he says
it sounds like you need Trump lockers
soft lockers
what are those Trump lockers are the
hottest shades that make you think
you like said something instead of
Donald Trump just put these glasses on
and you'll instantly see the truth from
who you want to hear from I built an
unbelievable company a great comfort I
filed papers with federal election you
don't build companies like that unless
you have the right Republicans want to
protect Medicare for our great seniors
who have earned it and who have paid for
it all their lives wow that makes sense
women's unemployment has just fallen to
3.6 percent which is only the lowest
rate in 65 years upside wow that's a
good point
the elite the elite why are they elite I
have a much better apartment than they
do I'm smarter than they are
I'm richer than they are
how does Obama come up with this stuff
so get your truck lockers today
I love my Trump blockers but there is
one side effect even when I'm not
wearing it
hey Timmy how was your weekend and you
know at the end of the week I meet with
China I meet with a lot of other
countries that have not treated us too
well but we're doing extremely well see
what I mean hey cat looking good
other than the blonde hair when I was
growing up they said I look like Elvis
you see that totally
thanks Trump lockers
[Applause]
all right let's welcome tonight's guest
his tattoos could beat up your tattoos
retired Green Beret Master Sergeant
Terry Schappert he's a mole with no soul
and could leave you in a hole former CIA
operative intelligence president Mike
Baker her classes are as thick as
molasses National Review reporter Kat
tips every step he takes creates a new
pool for the kids former WWE Superstar
massive psychic and host of on PC on Fox
Nation Tyrus Terry I think that that's
the solution you take everything Trump
says and filter it through the body of
Obama and you get if you have the world
you have the perfect thing you just you
just solve everything in the country
right there I did I do that I like to do
that yeah you might get stopped also
your shoe choices it's not going to
happen okay just so you know America
they say nothing backstage and I come
out here and they give me a bunch of
stuff a by the way yes well done thank
you hey you don't remind you remember
that movie stop touching me they live
they live oh I stole this from they live
okay cuz the Bob by the way one of my
favorite sci-fi movies John Carpenter
rowdy roddy piper right he puts the if
they haven't seen it it's worth seeing
it's a really great move he puts on the
glasses and then he sees that basically
all these authority figures are actually
aliens that are running the show and
there's there's also subliminal messages
and he figures it out and it's like you
got to give this credit to trump as well
for this whether you like him or hate
him he's gotten us talking about the
who's who knew anything about I do
because I'm very smart them you know
words guys but like who knew anything
about NATO yeah who anything about NAFTA
we would anything about all the stuff so
people going wait a minute
because remember Trump looks at them at
America as the new Trump corporation
yeah I'm serious no yes
so he's sitting he's going hey hey hey
buddy what is this NATO thing we're
doing this we're not getting this not
enough fix that yeah
and so I I'm not saying that's always
the best way to go but it's actually
working because he's looking at
everything with a hard line going
I know it's been 20 30 40 years we're
getting screwed on this yeah you know
you know what it is Mike it's like okay
he's like a guy who takes over a
business and asks really dumb questions
that no one else laughs it's like you
know can we just get rid of this or can
we do that can we do that and then you
end up with a a national Poli Sci class
because I don't I don't know crap about
NATO
I don't know crap about trade I do I was
forced to I don't want to know these
things but but Trump because Trump ask
dumb questions
then the dumb questions go in a certain
path that leads to actually interesting
answers anybody show of hands anybody
was interested in watching the g20
summit right no we can't know is we
can't show the audience yeah so yeah
it's in and you're right it's just like
in the old school days right yeah when
nobody wanted to ask the question but
then when you finally got that one kid
who just yeah I don't get it he that's
the question everybody else was like I
thank God he said that yeah nobody knew
what that was going on that's fixed yeah
yeah but you know what I mean it's it's
we're gonna have this for the next four
years
over the next two more years right
people keep talking about when is it
gonna happen we want some resistance
going away when is it they go what are
they gonna wind this down they're not is
the answer yes like the Muller
investigation is not going away it's
gonna keep ticking along yeah we are
going to be talking about this because
that means the world we live in
yeah it is the world that's one of those
statements you can say to wrap things up
yes wrap things up say tends to ramble
there and 80 to 90% of what he says we
don't even know my research if you don't
cat you always do your research you do
you do you do this is why I think Trump
kept asking if you could fire people
because you didn't know it can I find
that person that's just I couldn't fire
the police or if guy because he just
doesn't you know and then they somehow
stumble towards an answer and he ends up
being right well it doesn't matter what
he does people who are liberal are still
gonna hate him because the election
broke their hearts right the way that
they feel about Trump is exactly the way
I feel about my ex-boyfriend of course
know no matter what he does it doesn't
matter he could my ex boyfriend could
invent a cure for the common cold
would I
give him credit for it no I would start
a cult that teaches that sneezing and
coughing are the way into heaven it's
it's weird that they're so emotionally
affected because they'd like don't even
know the guy
yeah no and it controls all their
emotions it's quite sad I think though
in a way we all know Trump because we
have someone like him in our lives
I always calm the the rich obnoxious
uncle who knows everything and so when
he comes over
I think I'm that guy but generally I
just go sit in the garage and get drunk
tyrus because I do
sure absolutely I've seen him do it he
gets drunk in the garage all the time
great now let's go to commercial yeah do
you have a question no because I assume
do you have a garage you are have you
have a way to wrap this all together I'm
very proud of you that you solved the
division in this country yes Barack
Obama and Trump Trump's voice who
together they cheered for Barack Obama
so this is a big on this show you being
weird
and you say Obama or you say Hillary you
against the boos the only thing I think
even if you took Hillary with Trump's
voice you'd still get a couple no it is
an amazing moment yes man I'm glad I was
this is like watching somebody walk on
the moon for the first time it's a good
step forward we can just walk into the
next town hall people yelling or
screaming each other I will set up the
projector yes watch this show I'm
telling you you've done it I've done it
I've got it
I think I bottle I'm gonna leave later
oh no no no we get them but with
speaking of which Hillary up next that's
called the transition yeah thank you
very much I'm a pro